ich mein ich bin ein heftiger spaßt in
einen der letzten videos habe ich mir
für 5500 euro eine gute jacke bestellt
dann habe ich ein kurzes simulator
gespielt ich kann einfach alles ankotzen
auch die aktion die es heute geht weil
er da man eher den weg bereitete
eingeblendet die hat wirklich leider
alles getoppt was ich bisher an dummheit
von mir hochgeladen habe ich habe meine
unterhose auf ebay verkauft
ja aber wie kam es dazu eigentlich kurze
background story eben dazu und zwar habe
ich vor einigen tagen ein video
hochgeladen in dem ich auf der zuschauer
videos reagiert habe diese kosteten wir
sind einfach voll fürn arsch wenn das
bei euch klappt dann verkaufe ich meine
unterhose babbel das war eigentlich
quasi schon die ganze szene
ich habe quasi gegen ein video gebettete
und das blöde war nur dass die das
geschafft haben wo wollt ihr mich
komplett verarschen und mein wetteinsatz
war halt es sich meiner unterhose auf
ebay verkaufen
ja das habe ich dann getan artikel
einstellen über 160 millionen käufer
wollen was sie haben angebot erstellen
genau beschreiben sie ihren artikel
unterhose von ok ich hab jetzt einfach
mal calvin klein unterhose eingegeben
dann kommen die hier und jetzt muss ich
die ganzen sachen ausfüllen also ich mag
die damals in die wehr rein und dann
zeige ich euch mal das angebot da bin
ich mit meiner boxershorts okaz
unterhose weiß large wie neu
verkäufer border ist mein name mensch
dreser luca 69 ich glaube ich habe ein
bisschen was falsch ausgewählt hier
steht das ist neu mit etikett neuer
unbenutzt noch nicht getragen
lange unterhosen
kommt drauf an ihm entlang definiert
hier hab ich dann auch noch meine
unterhose beschrieben
das ist meine unterhose in weiß größe l
super teil und bevor man in action video
wurde überhaupt sage dass ich meine
unterhose auf der stelle bevor das
überhaupt online gehen war die unterhose
schon bei 91 euro das also da dachte ich
mir schon das ist ja unmenschlich viel
für eine unterhose eine stunde nachdem
ich das video hochladen habe war die
unterhose 311.000 euro und eine stunde
später war die unterhose
das kann echt keine zählt wunder 33.300
euro für eine gottverdammte boxershort
von einem volltrottel wie mir an
denjenigen der dort 100 33.300 euro
geboten hat bist du noch zu retten um
das erstmal direkt zu beginn hier
klarzustellen selbstverständlich waren
das wahrscheinlich einfach irgendwelche
spaß geboten
das waren wahrscheinlich irgendwelche 10
11 12 jährigen kinder die sich gedacht
haben hey ich klicke war da drauf und
das war papa noch angemeldet dann ja das
kind xy einfach 133000 euro von papas
kreditkarte da drauf gebucht das ding
ist allerdings dass es bei ebay so was
wie spaß geboten nicht gibt das heißt
wenn das ganze weiter gelaufen wäre
hätte die person des 400 33.300 euro
wirklich kaufen müssen und ich hätte
erstmal ein paar jahre keine videos mehr
hochladen müssen so weit ist es
allerdings zum glück nicht gekommen dass
ich jetzt hier das gleiche erstmal
möchte ich euch gerne ein paar
kommentare bzw fragen zeigen die mir zu
dieser auktion gesendet wurden hast du
die unterhose auf wenigstens einmal
getragen sonst will ich die nicht panels
schöne frage sehr geehrter herr luca ich
verstehe nicht was an dieser unterhose
so besonders sein soll anscheinend
wissen da viele leute mehr
preis der unterhose bereits bei 91 euro
liegt ich bin verwirrt bitte um
aufklärung liebe grüße christopher ja
lieber christopher das kann ich dir ganz
einfach erklären das ist einfach meine
unterhose
ja dies euch auch nicht 1 90 euro wert
also nee wirklich lieber christopher ich
kann mir das passwort ist wirklich auch
nicht erklären
das ist wirklich tatsächlich und erkläre
ich solche kommentare aber ich aber
wirklich sehr sehr sehr sehr häufig
bekommen dass irgendwelche älteren
personen meinten hey ich hab gerade nach
unten geschaut auf deine gesehen ist die
irgendwie limitiert warum kostet die
gerade über 300 400 euro kann spiel das
man erklären wie gesagt ihr wisst
bescheid das war eine wette mit euch
meinen zuschauern aber wir kommen zur
nächsten frage artikel wurde gemeldet
bitte um entfernung des postens hat sich
diese frage bekommen habe habe ich mir
erst mal gedacht hey warum wird das
gemeldet in dem moment stand die
unterhose gerade bei weise nicht 300 400
euro das ding ist natürlich klar das ist
ein hoher preis habe ich habe mich
einfach mal was habe ich falsch gemacht
ich bin einfach nur ein unschuldiger
junger der sich quasi gedacht hat hey
ich brauche die unterhose nicht mehr
verkauft die auf ebay was ich genau
falsch gemacht habe werde ich nachher
erklären auch sehr gut fand ich
allerdings eher die nachricht gesendet
wurde mit dem inhalt du stinkst
dankeschön auf jeden fall dafür
verkaufen sie noch mehr unterhosen wenn
ich acht unterhosen verkauft hätte dann
hätte ich jetzt eine million euro
neue geschäftsideen kann ich hätte
interesse an der unterhose aus welchem
material besteht diese sind
besonderheiten vorhanden oder wieso der
teure preis nach was durfte die
unterhose kann man so ausprobieren
vorbeikommen würde mich auf antwort
freuen
kein scheitern ich glaube die person
meinte das wirklich ernst und dann kam
tatsächlich 1 kommentar bisher sei eine
frage die ich euch jetzt einfach mal
hier einwände freunde das ist viel zu
lang das ganze vorzulesen beschwert sich
allerdings wirklich eine ebay userin
darüber ob ich denn irgendeine form von
anstand besetzte mir sowas überhaupt zu
erlauben so was hochzuladen
dass sie den inhalt meiner videos eh
schon total bescheuert findet und das
ist ihnen eine möglichkeit gibt dieses
angebot bei ebay zu melden
das ist einfach nur unfassbar ist und
bla bla bla bla bla sie beleidigt mich
quasi die ganze zeit das tut mir sehr
leid aber das ganze war wirklich nur ein
spaß
es ist schade dass es wirklich viele
leute nicht verstanden haben natürlich
ist ebay ich will das überhaupt nicht
helfen das ist eine professionelle
plattform die sehr cool ist das ist
keine werbung für diese plattform also
ich will das jetzt nicht irgendwie gute
rede oder hat einen korb mit denen oder
was ich war jetzt war wirklich einfach
nur eine spaßaktion ich habe mir gedacht
hey leute
wenn die das schaffen und verkauft er
meine unterhose bei ebay es nicht
geschafft deswegen auch ich meine
unterhose in ebay gestellt allerdings
war es wirklich von beginn an geplant
dass ich ein oder zwei tage später bei
ebay anrufe und sagen hey das angebot
gerne unternehmen das war das nun
spaßaktion es hat ja auch sein können
dass niemand auf die unterhose bietet
und die bei 1 euro bleibt denn dann
hätte sich die einfach wieder selbst
runter genommen ich hätte allerdings
wirklich nie gedacht dass dort
irgendwann dieser preis steht also real
talk wer rechnet denn mit 133000 euro
für eine unterhose das ist das ist
sportwagen als ich diese nachricht dann
auf jeden fall gelesen habe und mir all
gemeinsam gedanken darüber gemacht habe
was da überhaupt gerade passiert ist
133000 euro hat jemand vom eine
gottverdammte unterhose geboten da
natürlich uns gedacht hey ich muss
eigentlich direkt bei ebay anrufen an
dem tag des uploads war es dann
irgendwie schon 8 9 uhr als der ganze
preis so hoch war nach ein paar stunden
deswegen hab ich gesagt hey am nächsten
morgen rufe ich bei ebay an als ich das
ganze allerdings tun wollte war es schon
zu spät also nicht in dem sinne dass die
auktion irgendwie vorzeitig beendet
wurde und jemand wirklich 133000 euro
verwender unterhose bezahlt sondern die
aktion wurde schon runtergenommen
entfernt delete ebay hat sich schon
gedacht das müssen wir stoppen warum hat
sich ebay das gedacht nun ja ich kann ja
mal einfach ein bisschen aus der mail
vorlesen beim überprüfen ihres
ebay-kontos haben wir festgestellt dass
sie sich nicht an unseren grundsatz
gebrauchte kleidung gehalten haben
gebrauchte unterhosen und socken und
damen strumpfhosen auch gereinigt dürfen
bei ebay generell nicht angeboten werden
das heißt im umkehrschluss dass ebay
meine option nicht runter genommen hat
bzw entfernt hatte weil dort irgendwie
so einen preis geboten wurde und das im
sechsstelligen bereich lag sondern ein
weise gebrauchte unterhose war und das
darf man auf ebay nicht verkaufen ich
stell mir halt gerade so die frage hey
was wäre denn gewesen wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise gesagt hätte hätte ich
verkaufe auf wenn ich meine unterhose
sondern diese brille sexy oder dann
hätten nämlich nicht mit diesem
grundsatz kommen können und wenn ich da
nicht angerufen hätte hätte wirklich
jemand 133000 euro für diese brille
bezahlt sexy oder und tatsächlich meine
damen und herren sie diese mail erhalten
habe habe ich mir natürlich auf der
einseitigen sagt hey geil ich muss mir
bei ihm anrufen
ich habe eh schon irgendwas falsch
gemacht so das angebot gut runter
genommen alle sind cool
die leute können ihr geld behalten ich
kann meine und ausweiten doch als ich
dann auf die seite gegangen bin von dem
produkt und ich habe wirklich gesehen
wir haben überall gesucht und das kind
ist im regenmantel wir schon passiert
die drängt gekommen war in richtung des
anders ticken es waren sicher in eine
mega lustige aktion finde ich es ist
total spontan gekommen im video gesagt
ey com ihr schafft das nicht die haben
es geschafft habe meine unterhose wieder
gestellte waren bei 133 euro ich mein
ich bin fußballer einfach hey leute das
ist einfach wirklich viel zu krass also
viele leute habe ich halt noch mal
gefragt herr luca was letztlich mit der
unterhose passiert wir finden nicht mehr
bei ebay
das war ja mein bild mit der unterhose
sehr schön ja das waren jetzt hier alle
informationen dazu und es wurde einfach
runter genommen tatsächlich nicht mal so
hoch war der preis oder so sondern weil
eine gebrauchte unterhose war mega
lustige story für mich eigentlich am
jahr schreibt mir mal die haare was ich
als nächstes bei ebay verkaufen soll
lassen leid da wäre die aktion auch
gefeiert habe leute sorry an alle die
ich nie verliert habe oder die jetzt
sauer auf mich war dass ich dabei der
unterhose reinstellen ich wusste selbst
nicht dass jemand so viel geld dafür
bietet das war von beginn an nicht meine
absicht das ganze wirklich normal enden
zu lassen dass irgendwann mein hund
hause kaufen kann sorry wir kennen mich
ich bin einfach voll der spaß
[Musik]